Larry is with us in Florida I Larry
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
greetings and Merry Christmas Dave boy
you're fired up today I like that duck
analogy and I just want to cause to
thank you for all the profound life
lessons and life changing directions who
give all of us were finished graduates
of Financial Peace University and
dedicated and into everything Ramsey
thank you for your work your team and
Kellie's great work I wanted to come to
you with a difficult property management
judgment issue was if we were Winston or
some other colleague of yours Dave or
Uncle Dave this is the facts and then
I'll get your input and I think it might
be helpful for other people too my
family has a summer home up in the
Northeast in New Hampshire and it's in a
somewhat rural area we spend only about
a total of eight weeks there we have
great neighbors and get along well with
everyone and a Jake immediately adjacent
property was sold in this this past May
to a very young couple with a young
child
they don't appear to have traditional
employment positions I have not
personally met them nor have any of the
other three neighbors I think the
feeling is that they may be not that
friendly people this new couple or be
that as it may we recently were alerted
by one of our other neighbors that a
very large number of heavy wooden
shipping pallets had been dumped on our
property that had been observed on this
neighbors property and we have
documentary proof of that and we wanted
to get your thoughts on how was the best
thing I don't really have the option I
won't be back up there actual April I
don't have the option to knock on their
door and greet them and having viewed
them I'm not sure I would I'm a senior
citizen I they just they look I don't
think they'd be candidates for jobs at
Ramsey operations days but the three
options we came up for them were to
personally write a letter to them UPS
and maybe have an attorney write a
letter to them
option C present the matter to the
police who I think would be very
supportive because the statutes have
very major coding and penalties if it's
over 15 pounds of stuff that you dumped
on someone's property you can end up at
least under the statute books with your
driver's license suspended for up to six
months and community service cleaning
things the other option that we were
leaning in favor of was option for
having a private investigator go over
read them ask them you know see if
they'll admit to what they've done
regardless ask them to have the private
stuff removed not put on any other
neighbor's property and taken to a dump
or otherwise disposed of and give them a
deadline and if that was ignored then go
to the police but we wanted to get uncle
Dave's view we try to get along with
neighbors and in we had the mindset that
we're very rarely on the property it's
not a rural area but it's semi rural we
have otherwise excellent neighbors yeah
okay do you have any contact with the
police department up there at all
chief of police unfortunately that we
will personally suddenly died of a heart
attack we don't know the gentleman
that's taken over his position but we
have every reason to believe they do
support us yeah I wasn't that I was just
wondering if rather than sending the
police I just don't want to over over do
this and it create more hostility
I'd rather create a minimum amount of
conflict or drama to get the response
that I want and then if that doesn't
work I can always turn up the heat no
pun intended but the you feel about the
private investigator as long as there's
someone that has the right kind of
demeanor if they go over there acting
like Barney Fife it's not gonna doing
good but I would send them with a
message hey we want to be good neighbors
you probably didn't realize it that's
over on our line maybe you thought it
was your property line or something but
it's clearly on their property line
they're out of town they would have come
by themselves but they couldn't cuz
they're never here
and you know if you guys will take care
of this and just be good neighbors then
everything will be cool and and if they
you know go ahead and authorize your guy
if they don't give a positive response
to that then you would just say you know
really we don't want to have to go these
other routes but I mean we can contact
an attorney and you know we could have a
judgement put against you you could turn
it over the police and they can come
down and visit you we don't want to do
all that we just want to be good
neighbors and so you we're just going to
pretend like you did this accidentally
and that you're going to clean it up and
we're all going to be great neighbors
and just get the stuff back on your
property or get rid of it one of the two
it can't stay on our property large it's
a very large volume and it looks like
they've almost must you use the truck
because it's way over clearly onto our
property but no that's not the point the
point is they got okay Indian is I'm
going to give them a nice option to just
clean it up as kindly as possible if
that doesn't work then I'm going to turn
it up if that doesn't work then I'm
gonna turn it up turning it up will you
be concerned about retaliation and
damage to the proper altar yeah
absolutely and if they do that I'll put
them in jail yeah I can turn it up again
like I'm not gonna be intimidated by
these people I'm gonna be kind to them
and firmly explain that we're not going
forward with this kind of behavior and
yeah I actually if you do nothing then
they're gonna get the idea they can do
whatever the flip they want to do over
at your place yeah so doing nothing is
probably going to invite more trouble
than hostility but again
to have your guy don't go over there and
just be a jerk and trying to you know
throw his weight around be Barney Fife
or something just go over and be kind
and look guys we can do this the easy
way the hard way we don't want to do it
the hard way we won't be good neighbors
we want to say you know you you guys
obviously maybe you messed up you didn't
realize this was our property but you're
over on our line and and you know you
need to get this cleaned up in the next
ten days or two weeks or so and if you
don't then you know you'll be getting on
a turn a letter from our attorney and
you know we're not cleaning it up well
then we'll just seen the police down
here and they'll write you up for this
and then you're going to clean it up
so here's the way here's the thing we're
gonna you're gonna clean this up it's
just my we're gonna at the hardware this
software and we just want to be good
neighbors man and good neighbors don't
dump crap on other people's property I
mean you know so you just say you just
have a kind gentle firm message and
don't invite trouble and if you can help
it but not dealing with it is also
inviting trouble
so you're smart to address it but I
think if the first thing you do send the
police down there you're gonna get in a
hostile reaction obviously so let's give
them a shot at just being a good
neighbor and just person to person you
know and they guys you know the folks
would have come over here but they live
out of town and they're only up here a
few weeks in the summer and you know you
need to get this done the next two weeks
I'm gonna check back and make sure it's
cleaned up in two weeks and if it's not
cleaned up in two weeks then we're gonna
have to take other steps okay please
don't please don't make us do that and
that's that's how we would do it if it
was our property and we do that kind of
stuff all the time with tenants and with
neighbors and trees falling over the
property line on someone else's property
and onto ours and stuff like that all
the time
anytime your own property more stuff you
own the more repairmen you have to know
and the more conflict you get to have
it's just part of it it's so it's no way
around it amen thanks for the call I
wish I hope that helps you but I you
know I think your the way you've
assessed these folks you don't have a
high opinion of them taking the soft
route so just be prepared to go ahead
and quickly ratchet the heat up and just
say we're gonna send the police and the
you know the folks down there and have
to call that Chief of Police and just go
hey stop by talked to them maybe you can
talk them out of it without having to
actually file a warrant with you but we
can file criminal but maybe you can just
talk to them and you know kind of do you
know Andy versus Barney instead of
sending Barney down there let's send
Andy down there and you know he could
always work it out you know that kind of
thing
so you know sometimes that'll help
because they don't wanna get crosswise
with the local police folks if they're
smart even if they're running criminal
activity especially if they're running
criminal activity